Jared I got to ask you what the hell's
going on in Mexico with this El Chapo
and the uh Cartel War against the
government
oh I'm going to pop up in Mexico City uh
Mexico City where I live haven't really
even historically during the drug war
didn't really see too much uh violence
around here although I was in
Guadalajara at the time Guadalajara got
hit really bad and that about that point
is when I got the hell out of here my
first time around so it's starting to
Echo kind of what happened in 2008 time
frame or so when they came down they
introduced plan Mexico they gave the
Mexican Government a bunch of money to
go against the cartels and it
effectively almost created a civil war
so we're all kind of holding our breath
here to make sure that doesn't happen
again but uh seeing in the news and
seeing the memes they arrested El
Chapo's son they brought him here to
Mexico City he's now in Mexico State at
the same prison that El Chapo escaped
from twice so we'll see what happens
there and then uh sure enough Biden and
Trudeau are in town this next week so
I'm sure historically whenever they have
those kind of meetings here in Mexico
they introduced some plan that always
screws over Mexico and either devalues
the peso or it injects a bunch of cash
into Mexican government so they can go
after their cartels and then it just
erupts in violence so we're all kind of
like oh no we've seen this before we
know where this is going to lead uh
Trudeau and Biden are both idiots I know
that we all know that so and then Mexico
has a socialist president too he's not
he's not as bad as I thought he would be
I think he's more ineffective than
actively bad like a Biden or Trudeau but
like oh no we have three North American
socialist-leaning leaders and they just
did this whole little operative ticket
El Chapo sun right before their
conference here in Mexico City so we're
just holding our breaths
um I've I've seen this before and it uh
the last time around it was not fun
being down here when that [ __ ] kicked
off visitors now is what it was last
time because I've seen footage of them
burning buses uh shooting at planes with
50 cows
um all kinds of stuff that's in Sinaloa
so it's usually
is the capital city of that state that's
where they have a lot of that stuff like
that too
uh manzanillo is in a different state
that's further down that's south of uh
Puerto Vallarta but um when I lived here
before it kind of went in waves so
whenever there was Turf type Wars so
Guadalajara was immune to it for a while
Monterrey up in the north which is a
really nice city got hit really bad and
then uh when I was down here it was
later like 2010 I think 2011 when
Guadalajara got hit I remember I was
there when they had an operative they
took out the the Capo or the head guy
his name was Al Barbee because he was a
white guy with a fair European looking
characteristics and my buddy and I we
were up on the roof of our house playing
dominoes drinking beer just watching as
a whole city erupted in violence and
it's it's pretty it's pretty typical the
way they do it that happened in Tijuana
a few months ago where uh they bomb out
buses to set up roadblock AIDS and they
do coordinated attacks against the
police and military and uh when I when I
witnessed it in Guadalajara helicopters
were coming in and they're coming
repelling down and grabbing people so my
buddy and I are sitting on the roof
watching or playing dominoes we're like
God this looks like Afghanistan and uh I
had had foreign friends that this was
back in the the mid-2000s that had been
deployed to Afghanistan and Iraq like
yeah this is this is pretty much you
know what what a war zone looks like
like well since I can choose where I
want to live I choose not to live here
anymore so fingers crossed that's not
going to happen this time around I'm a
little more mobile I like Mexico City
but I I have my life set up to where I
don't have to live here forever so I'm
still minimalist enough to where in two
days I can get the hell out of here and
go on to wherever I I need to go so
fingers crossed nothing nothing that
comes of it um it's a one-off thing but
you never know the way politics work uh
these days so John yeah essentially
you're getting to see season four of
Miracles without having to watch it on
Netflix yeah I've still never watched
narcos when my friends in the states
like dude you gotta watch narcos like no
I live down here during that first time
I don't I don't want to watch it it got
pretty scary I don't want to see that
again I thought there was just like a
general understanding you know we won't
bother any of the population of the
tourists if you just leave us alone but
it but it seems like that that like
agreement has sort of been uh cast aside
for some reason huh that's exactly how
it is so when I first moved to
Guadalajara was in 2006 it was a really
peaceful town and I believe I've done my
research at the time too that the murder
rate was comparable to like your major
European cities and it felt like Europe
it was a really pretty town really calm
really chill thriving nightlife thriving
middle class and then once it was our
turn to get our wave in the drug
violence all the nightclubs closed
there's curfews not government imposed
curfews but most people like the knights
were dead there's nothing going on it
just kind of sucked the life out of the
city so
um that's my understanding that's the
way I approach those things if you run
into those types of characters just hey
you know you stay in your lane I stay in
my lane and that there is a general
societal understanding and I I get
really pissed off whenever the U.S tries
to meddle a Mexican Affairs because they
always they always just fracture the
society and it's usually the civilian
population that uh catches the the bad
end of that stick what's the drugs that
they're fighting over is it is it Coker
I have no idea I think fentanyl is a big
one now though a lot of a lot of drugs
that come down here come from the U.S
like all the marijuana here is from
California
um I think it's fit and all going north
I think human trafficking's a big one
nowadays
um to be honest I'm not I'm not really
sure I'm not I'm not in the the drug
thing too much aside from a little weed
here and there got it yeah I got a
message from 50. he said his uh computer
crash so he'll be back
there's an update from this guy called
uh Johnny Mitchell yeah that does uh the
connect it's called I just happened to
listen to it update on on what exactly
on what's happening in Mexico okay what
do they say
um basically he said that every four or
five years one's one of the heads of the
cartels goes to large too powerful to
exposed to start stalking posting and
being too public they take him down even
though
the government and everybody from the
um president down is deprived by these
guys at some point they just get too big
and the Americans have to do something
and push the Mexican Government
and they need to do something about
these guys
so somebody else just comes and takes
their place
but it's all for show is like it's all
for political points too it's not an
accident that it happened right before
Biden's visiting the southern Border in
the U.S for the first time and before
the North American leader summer here I
think it's next early next week that's
happening because I was supposed to go
to the US for business and then uh you
guys internally know one of the big
companies I work for like hey we need a
Mexico City you know to like receive
people as part of you know the whole
thing going on I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full-length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out